foreign
[Music]
admitted that we live that if we lived
in a sane Society not a perfect one but
merely a sane one then I wouldn't have a
job at least I wouldn't have this job
because my job at present consists
largely of saying very obvious things
things that would not need to be said in
a country where sanity rained uh things
that if they were said in a sane country
that they'd be met with yawning slightly
bemused reactions people would respond
yeah and why are you telling us this and
they get back to their lives but because
Insanity rather than sanity Reigns here
it is necessary to State the obvious and
the obvious when stated will nearly
always be met with screams of horror and
breathless enunciations from people who
believe that there is nothing so
offensive as a thing that is obviously
true
and that brings us to the latest
controversy the latest Firestorm that I
find myself in the middle of uh it began
last week on this show and I dedicated
Thursdays I think it was Thursday's
daily cancellation to a so-called
divorce coach who among other things
advised women that if their husbands
have grown unhappy or bitter through the
course of their marriage it's because
the husband was always an angry person
whose mask has finally fallen off
now I countered that it's certainly
possible that a man might fool his
betrothed by donning a mask which slips
during the course of the marriage
revealing his true and miserable self
however I suggested a woman who notices
that her husband is turning into such a
person would do well to consider that
his happiness might not be baggage he
secretly brought into the marriage but
rather a change that has taken place
during the marriage
she should think about whether she is
giving her husband what he most wants
and needs
she'd think about whether she is helping
her husband to be happy or if she is
facilitating his unhappiness and the
good news as I explained is that the
wants and needs of a man are generally
pretty simple
what most men want is simply to come
home from work to a wife and children
who are happy to see them and grateful
for him and uh you know with dinner
cooking on the stove that doesn't hurt
either
of course as I acknowledge during the
segment not everyone's situation is
exactly the same and even in the ideal
scenario it can't be like that every day
in fact even in my specific case you
know I I really like to cook so there
are plenty of days when I cook and my
wife cleans up the dishes afterwards
um there are variations on this basic
theme variations that also have to
account for the fact that there are
plenty of households especially in this
economy where both the husband and the
wife have to work they're forced to work
or they've decided that they have to
work
so I'm not laying out a precise
unchangeable formula that must apply to
everyone every day no matter what
rather I'm trying to explain that in
most cases
a Man simply wants to provide for his
family he wants his work and his
sacrifices to be noticed and appreciated
he wants his wife to love him and be
affectionate towards him and care for
him
and uh and respect him
and he wants his children to love him
and appreciate him and respect him and
be excited to see him
whatever exact shape this takes if a man
can have all of that he will be happy if
a man does not have that he will
probably not be happy
this is the point I made during the
segment which my team also posted to
tick tock in which I reiterated in a
tweet over the weekend
on Twitter I posted this which is what I
just said uh quote all a man wants is to
come home from a long day at work to a
grateful wife and children who are glad
to see him and dinner cooking on the
stove this is literally all it takes to
make a man happy we are simple give us
this and you will have given us nearly
everything we need
okay
Zach brings you up to speed
and then came the responses which break
down along the lines you might expect
across the platforms where we've had
this conversation
most men have answered either that they
have exactly what I described and they
love it or they aren't married yet but
they hope to have it when they are
married or they are married and they
wish they had that but instead they come
home to an unkempt unappreciative
household and a nagging wife every day
then it makes them very miserable
very few men have said that they
categorically do not desire anything
resembling the situation I described
the feminists on the other hand have had
quite a different reaction there have
been hundreds if not thousands of
outbreak well thousands actually of
outrage responses to my provocative
claim that men want to be loved and
respected by their wives and children
and um
I'll read through just a few of them a
few examples uh here's one from
notorious cat lady Jill philopovich who
tweeted get yourself doordash and a dog
and please leave women alone then she
continues this manages to be insulting
to women and men at the same time and
clearly if your husband is unhappy or
abusive it's your fault for not having
dinner ready or being sufficiently happy
anyway I'm glad to know men who actually
like women as people and want
partnership not a servile wife as Mommy
who breeds silent and compliant children
and asserts no needs of her own
Elizabeth Spears who's a democratic
consultant who made it onto the show
several months ago after writing a
column claiming that adoption is more
traumatic than abortion
she was especially incense She Wrote
the kind of man who wants this believes
that women exist solely to serve his
needs and in relationships where that is
true the relationship is partly about
power and control a root cause of
domestic violence later she posted this
service model of relationships often
doesn't work even when women want to
play that role because Matt is an
overgrown baby and doesn't understand
that men can get all of those things and
still be abusive and cheat and be
unhappy themselves
another woman in media Jennifer Robison
who um claims to not be a feminist
posted your domestic Tableau is creepy
because it focuses only on your needs it
is you surveying your family as objects
that exist only to please you not
considering that they are discreet
humans with their own drives and desires
now there are many other responses like
this and not all from female feminists
some from even the even more pathetic
male variety of feminists and all
labeling me a sexist a caveman a
backwards abusive troglodyte stuck in
the past Etc and uh most accusing me of
making additional statements that I
never made there were also comments
sharing violent fantasies about my
family which I won't repeat suffice it
to say that we live in a deeply depraved
culture one where people lash out at
what is normal they attack normalcy
itself
and that's the first point I want to
make about all this
and if you disagree with what I said
either because you don't believe that
that's actually what men want or because
you don't think men should want it
there is no question that I was
articulating a very normal very
conventional and and very traditional
idea
one that most men through history can
relate to even prior to the Industrial
Age and the invention of the nine to
five job
that doesn't automatically mean that you
you can't be critical of the man as
Breadwinner Arrangement or of men who
want to come home to a loving wife and a
hot dinner I mean if you want to
criticize that sure go ahead and try
but it does make you an utterly
ridiculous and unserious person if you
treat the concept as somehow shocking
and offensive
you can try to find a reason to oppose
the way that billions of men and women
have chosen to live their lives but what
you can't do is treat it like some
freakish shocking outrageous thing
by comparison just as analogy
lots of people like Star Wars right I
don't like Star Wars now I'm free to
disagree with the tastes and preferences
of the majority of people but I would
come off like a blabbering lunatic if
someone said that Star Wars was their
favorite movie and I reacted by shouting
what are you kidding me Star Wars you
like that movie I've never heard of
anyone who likes that
in fact you might suspect that my
argument against Star Wars is rather
weak if I feel the need to
overcompensate by pretending that I'm
astonished to hear that the film has any
fans at all
but this is all the left ever does
they treat totally normal traditional
ideas and value systems as not only
wrong but appalling and bizarre
they do this because they have no real
argument against what is normal and
traditional all they have is their
theatrical protestations and they hope
that that will be enough
one other thought in this vein note that
if instead of expressing a desire to
come home to a loving wife and children
if a man instead were to you know
Express a desire to say become a
genderqueer trans woman and join a
polyamorous furry BDSM sex cult
the same people attacking him now would
instead forcefully defend the validity
of his lifestyle choices and preferences
that's because any and all desires are
celebrated by the left
unless they are normal and healthy and
traditional ones
second point
I have been criticized for discussing
what a man needs and what a man wants
without saying anything about what a
woman needs and a woman wants this has
been willfully misinterpreted as a claim
that women don't need or want anything
or that their needs and wants are
unimportant
now I of course never said that and I
don't think it
I just simply didn't mention the needs
of women because that didn't happen to
be the subject that I was speaking about
at the time
okay
um just because a person is talking
about one subject it doesn't mean that
they are denying the importance of every
other subject they aren't talking about
in that moment
it is in fact okay to talk about men
without allotting equal or greater time
to a discussion about women there's
already plenty of air time taken up by
conversations about women and most of
the time when there's a discussion about
relationships it's going to be focused
on what women need
and what men need to do to fill those
needs
and yet if you spend even a few minutes
talking about the other side of that
coin you're accused of erasing or
marginalizing women
it's ridiculous
and also precisely the attitude that
makes this conversation necessary in the
first place
because the attitude for a lot of people
is that men are not allowed to talk
about what they want and what makes them
happy
women are allowed to talk about that but
men are not allowed to discuss it and if
you bring it up it is somehow offensive
you can't even talk about the needs and
wants of men without
automatically undermining the needs and
wants of women it is again totally
ridiculous and it's a game that I will
not play
third
many of my critics have taken special
exception to my use of the word grateful
um you know it's bad enough that I would
promote as they say a patriarchal and
sexist family Arrangement but it's even
worse that I would suggest that a wife
should be grateful to her husband and
for the sacrifices that he makes for the
family
this tweet from someone with a username
vmw is typical she says I'm far from
what one would call a feminist and as a
woman who was a stay-at-home mom and
does cook dinner most nights even I
objected to your grateful comment maybe
it's you who should try to try some
reevaluation of your thoughts regarding
a wife's role and motivation in marriage
well I've got some bad news for this
lady
if she doesn't think that she should
have gratitude for her husband if indeed
she thinks grateful is a dirty word
that it's highly probable that her
husband is unhappy and her marriage is
miserable a miserable drudgery for all
involved including the kids
gratitude is absolutely essential to any
happy marriage
and yes that means that the Gratitude
should go both ways
but if you hear someone say wives should
be grateful for their husbands and your
immediate response is oh yeah well what
about husbands huh they need to be
grateful too you know
if that's your response then you've
revealed yourself to be an emotional
child a self-centered brat reacting like
a three-year-old who sees that her
brother got slightly more ice cream in
her Bowl that's not fair but
that attitude is a perfect example of
what a lack of gratitude looks like in
practice
and it is absolutely toxic
fourth point
finally
rather than um
crying about the fact that so many men
desire to come home from work to a happy
and grateful family
you might take a moment to consider why
they desire it why we desire it
now it could be that we're all a bunch
of woman-hating psychopaths who hate
women so much that we married and
literally dedicated Our Lives to them
or
it could be that we are human beings who
feel that deepest of human longings to
love and be loved
we want to love our families by
providing for them we want to love them
by being useful to them
by giving them something that they need
this is why getting laid off or fired or
forced out of work for long stretches or
even retiring can sometimes be literally
deadly for a man
he feels deprived of the opportunity to
be useful
to love his family in an active and
productive way
this is what lies at the root of that
terrible evil patriarchal male urge to
be a breadwinner what lies at the root
is his desire to give to those he loves
how awful right
what a terrible thing
and yes he also wants to be loved he
wants to know that his efforts are
noticed and appreciated
he wants a warmth and love and affection
and gratitude and respect from his wife
and if he doesn't get it he'll be
unhappy
with a pain that he feels at the deepest
levels of his soul
but which he may never speak out loud
for as long as he lives
I mean a man won't usually say any of
this out loud especially these days when
he's certain to be shouted down you know
if he dare verbalize any of it
but it's the truth
and those who try to stop us from
acknowledging this truth we're talking
about it
they are the ones who are today canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show's move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]